in this video we will be discussing the
Addison's disease and Addison's disease
can be simply remembered as when adrenal
gland fails to produce the necessary
hormones before discussing Addison's
disease it is important to understand
the adrenal gland and its functions this
is the adrenal gland and the inner part
is the medulla the medulla secretes the
catecholamines the outer part is the
cortex and cortex secretes aldosterone
cortisol and sex steroids let's briefly
understand the function of these
hormones first coming to aldosterone
Alastor on increases the sodium and
water reabsorption in the kidneys it
also causes excretion of potassium
through the kidneys and aldosterone
helps to maintain a normal blood
pressure about the cortisol cortisol
stimulates gluconeogenesis in the liver
and helps to maintain a normal glucose
concentration of the blood it also
stimulates lipolysis throughout the body
cortisol depresses the immune response
and it also helps to decrease the
inflammation the sex steroids are mainly
associated with the development of
secondary sexual characteristics and it
is the deficient secretion of all these
adrenal hormones which causes to develop
Addison's disease coming to the etiology
of the Addison's disease the number one
cause will be the autoimmune adrenal
itis in which the body's own B cells and
the T cells attack the adrenal gland and
damage it the second cause will be
infections from organisms like
Mycobacterium tuberculosis and also
fungal infections like histoplasmosis
third cause will be the arena infarction
which happens in cases of systemic lupus
erythematosus and antiphospholipid
antibody syndromes
drugs like might retain and ketoconazole
when taken in excess can also damage the
adrenal gland metastasis from organs
like the lungs and the stomach also
damage the adrenal gland trauma to the
abdomen either blunt or sharp can also
damage the adrenal gland adrenal
hemorrhage which happens in cases of
waterhouse Fredrickson syndrome and
anticoagulation therapy can also cause
adrenal insufficiency storage disorders
like amyloidosis and hemochromatosis
also affect the adrenal gland and also
lastly the surgical removal of the
adrenal gland known as bilateral
adrenalectomy causes Addison's disease
now let's discuss the clinical features
of Addison's disease the clinical
features due to cortisol deficiency
usually manifest as fatigue
anorexia weight loss and muscle
weaknesses abdominal pain these patients
have frequent episodes of diarrhea and
they also have hypoglycemia which
manifests as sweating and headache
another important symptom of Addison's
disease is the hyperpigmentation which
occurs in areas like hands and the
buccal mucosa it is important to
understand why the hyperpigmentation
occurs this is the pituitary gland and
the pituitary secretes the propio
melanocortin which is converted into
melanocytes stimulating hormone and
adrenocorticotropic hormone the ACTH
acts on the adrenal and causes increase
in the secretion of cortisol and the
rest of it is converted into alpha MSH
in cases of Addison's disease the
cortisol secretion is decreased so
through a feedback mechanism there is a
reflex increase in the secretion of P om
see through the pituitary which causes
an increase in the secretion of a
message and ACTH and the increase a
message causes hyperpigmentation
features of aldosterone deficiency
since aldosterone is important for
maintaining normal blood pressure
addressed on deficiency manifests as low
blood pressure these patients also have
orthostatic hypotension that is the
blood pressure further Falls when they
rise up after setting aldosterone
deficiency also manifests as craving for
salty foods sex thyroid deficiency
usually manifests as loss of libido in
both sexes and menstrual irregularities
in females briefly talking about the
diagnosis of Addison's disease blood
glucose measurement usually shows a low
plasma blood glucose plasma cortisol
measured between 8:00 a.m. and 9:00 a.m.
show a value of less than 3 milligrams
per deciliter ACTH stimulation test is
important tests to diagnose Addison's
disease in which we give 250 milligrams
of exogenous ACTH to the patient in a
normal case the plasma cortisol should
rise above 19 milligrams per deciliter
but in Addison's disease the plasma
cutter soul does not rise above 90
milligrams per deciliter plasma is ETH
levels are usually elevated above 100
picograms per deciliter due to the
reflux increase in the ACTH levels in
cases of autoimmune original itis organ
specific antibodies can be detected in
the plasma of the patients like adrenal
cortex antibodies and 21 hydroxylase
antibodies the patients of Addison's
disease usually have anemia and Osuna
failure treatment of Addison's disease
usually depends upon the hormonal
replacement cortisol is replaced by
prednisone and those of five milligrams
in the morning and two point five
milligrams in the evening aldosterone is
replaced by fludrocortisone which is
given in a dose range of 0.05 to
point one milligrams per day and this
treatment usually runs lifelong one
quick mention I would like to do here is
the adrenal crisis which is certain
severe adrenal insufficiency occurring
in cases of stress infection it is a
life-threatening condition and requires
emergency management in the form of
intravenous injections of
glucocorticoids and also large volumes
of intravenous dextrose normal saline
solution so this was a brief overview
about the Addison's disease thank you so
much for watching this video make sure
to subscribe us on YouTube for all the
latest videos and also make sure to
follow us on Facebook for the latest
updates